welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and the first trailer for obi-wan
kenobi gave us our first live-action
look at one of the most badass and
influential forces in the entire star
wars universe the inquisitors of the
inquisitorius but who the hell are the
inquisitors of the empire anyway what is
their purpose and like how many have
there been these are all important
questions for people about to journey to
a galaxy far far away with obi-wan
kenobi have got to ask because my nerd
babies frankly these inquisitors do not
play around they're coming to take lives
so let us all come together and learn
about these big bad butchers in black
menard babies so as of 2022 there have
been a total of 14 confirmed inquisitors
in the star wars universe with the grand
inquisitor leading the inquisitorius
under darth vader's supervision the
inquisitorious or the inquisitorious
program being of course the dark force
of dark side users emperor palpatine and
darth vader tasked with hunting down all
the remaining jedi indoctrinated
blasphemers of the galaxy after order 66
while simultaneously searching for any
force sensitive younglings that they
could persuade to join in on papa
palpatine's purge making a purge patrol
that papa palpatine had prophesied in
the past as early as the clone wars with
palpatine literally saying as much to
his nanny droid taking care of all these
force sensitive babies that palpatine
hired cadbane of the book of boba fett
to steal in an attempt to create these
first generation of inquisitors the
natural talent these children possess is
too great to be wasted by the jedi i
foresee an army of force talented spies
in my service and my enemies would be
helpless against such vision but anyways
introducing the star wars rebels cartoon
the grand inquisitor is the main
mysterious manager of all of these jedi
murderers charged with leading and
training these brothers and sisters of
the inquisitorious according to darth
vader's agenda and is probably the most
popular for championing an obsessive
chase of the jedi kanan jairus and his
padawan ezra bridger on the series
hailing for the planet udapau you know
hence the facial markings and the
weirdly shaped head the mysterious powen
that we know only as the grand
inquisitor actually used to be a guard
for the jedi temple on the planet
coruscant but one who eventually would
end up flipping in faith in the ideals
of the jedi order after seeing how
terribly the jedi order handled ahsoka
being framed towards the end of the
clone wars series and then the emperor
would eventually use his growing disdain
of the jedi to make him his grand
inquisitor to hunt down the very people
that he swore to protect ironic and
spoiler alert for the fate of the grand
inquisitor but the grand inquisitor
would eventually be killed by the jedi
kanan jairus by the end of star wars
rebels and this is super messed up darth
vader would actually punish his failure
by preventing him from entering the
afterlife and instead forcing his
suffering soul to serve the empire as a
type of dark side security system like
basically a ghost with his ghost being
bested by a luke skywalker trespassing
on an old jedi temple but before he died
the grand inquisitor and the
inquisitorius frequently met up at their
highly fortified underwater base called
the fortress inquisitorius located on
the moon of nir and vader's mustafar
system whose interior can be seen here
in the trailer in this shot of third
sister fifth brother and this unnamed
tentacled inquisitor on the left and hey
speaking of this third sista by the name
of rava she is the newest inquisitor
canonized into the star wars mythos and
definitely the inquisitor who gets the
most green time in the obi-wan trailer
as actress moses ingram will apparently
be the inquisitor will be seeing chasing
and obi-wan on the ob run as the show's
main antagonist and with obi-wan series
director deborah chao describing the
third sister as relentlessly ambitious
obi-wan should probably consider wearing
a hood over his hood because reeve is
climbing on his buildings snatching his
people up trying to kill him so you
better hide your kids hide your wife and
hide your uncle owens because reeve is
after everybody out here but the one
homie in the break room inquisitorius
that we do know of is of course your boy
the fifth brother the murderer with the
goofy hat that we see later on in the
trailer marching down these neon streets
of the planet daio a former jedi himself
he's most known for helping the grand
inquisitor hunt down the jedi heroes of
the star wars rebels series alongside
his inquisitor partner and friendly
rival and murder the seventh sister and
both of them would clash with kanan ezra
and even the queen herself ahsoka before
they were both killed by a darth maul
absolutely wrecking shop on malachor
like
and of course the mysterious masked
inquisitor known as the eighth brother
would die soon after sister seven after
pulling a mr bean when he should have
pulled mary poppins with his helicopter
inquisitorious lightsaber whoops and
it's even more hilarious considering
that killing maul and malachor was
literally the one job the emperor gave
him so
and hey say what you will about their
actions and motives but do it quietly
but the inquisitors definitely have a
sense of style and you too can have a
great look with the help of our friends
over at epic hero shop they release all
kinds of merch based on the stuff that
we are excited about like marvel dc and
star wars and they actually just
re-released some of their limited
edition shirts based on the mandalorian
and the book of bubba fat and they also
have a really cool line based on the
many looks of moon knight they have a
really dope set of hoodies with one even
having a consu head logo and the phrase
embrace the chaos and the other having a
cool design inspired by the mr night
look which is a pretty dope look i can't
wait to see that in action so grab one
of each so you will always have one to
reflect on which side of the force that
you're feeling that day and they have
all types of clever and fun merch
inspired by spider-man no way home loki
peacemaker and all the other properties
that we are obsessed with and sign up
for their newsletter at the bottom of
their website to get notified about
merch drops and check out all of their
incredible products at the
epicheroshop.com be your own hero and yo
what is dope about the fortress
inquisitorius by the way is that it
actually first appeared in the gaming
masterpiece that is jedi fallen order
when five years before the events of
this obi-wan kenobi show the jedi calcus
had to infiltrate the fortress to steal
a jedi holocron from the incredibly
formidable inquisitor the second sister
a former jedi padawan by the name of
trilla suduri because you see trilla was
captured by the empire after her former
master the jedi seer junda caved to the
intense dark side of the force
interrogation tactics of the inquisitors
and told them where to find the young
padawan so trailer was unfortunately
tortured and basically forced to become
an inquisitor because of her master
using her hate for her former master
seer junda to sustain her as a tortured
seer was the one who sold her out to be
captured by the empire in the first
place but unluckily for trilla she's
pretty much immediately killed by darth
vader seconds after she makes up with
her former master so you know that's why
we don't see her here in the break room
with all the homies but with this
inclusion of the fortress inquisitorius
combined with you know a bd1 droid
showing up in freaking book of boba fett
i feel like we could very well see our
favorite red haired jedi knight calcus
appear at some point in this obi-wan
kenobi series which is super exciting to
me because i need to see him team up
with obi-wan yesterday and maybe
possibly we might see obi-wan helping
calcus in a rematch against the super
huge and resilient ninth sister who is
literally a beast of a darwutin
inquisitor and one of the most
physically strongest of all of them like
she straight up told calcus tis but a
scratch after he freaking cut off her
arm but hey if the ninth sister can
survive being hit by a tsunami on mon
calamari then she could probably survive
being tossed off a tree on kashi and
before she became the inquisitor of the
ninth sister masana tide honed her force
ability for emotions and reading minds
at the jedi temple but masana would soon
join sister 7 and brothers 5 6 and 8 as
one of the first inquisitors to train
under the grand inquisitor but those are
the main inquisitors that you really
have to know about with the rest only
playing minor roles in the comics or
other side material but i do have to
mention 10th brother because though he
only appeared in the star wars comics he
was actually a blind former jedi master
by the name of proset dibs before he
turned to the dark side after this huge
disagreement with mace windu and he's
kind of a badass like his dude is
completely blind and just freaking
fighting anyone he don't give a [ __ ] and
we also have to mention the masked six
brother bill valen who actually gets his
left arm cut off after challenging vader
in trading and his life cut off after
ahsoka blows up his lightsaber in her
book ahsoka which is great because uh
that dude relished in murder a little
bit too much for my taste and i'm just
gonna mention the fourth sister real
quick even though we technically have
never really seen her like only her
armor has been seen on someone else
because he was captured by the rebellion
there is a possibility that we could see
the person who used to own the fourth
sister's armor at some point in the
obi-wan show and the last three
inquisitors who aren't really all that
important are this black twilight and
this red alien woman who were killed by
vader for plotting against him and this
unknown female inquisitor who was killed
by her apprentice jurcera of dathomir
also there's apparently a third brother
that hasn't been seen anywhere but that
is basically everything you need to know
about the inquisitors before obi-wan
kenobi who is your favorite inquisitor
or just dark side user in general let us
know in the comment section below my
nerd babies but thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at mastertainment on twitter if you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and
also do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get dope
shirts like this batman shirt which is
amazing and i love it so much and of
course do not forget to search for us on
discord so you can join the conversation
over there because we're talking about
some really fun things and playing some
really fun games but anyways thank you
guys for spending time with me in this
video i love you guys so so so much i'll
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you